aujourd'hui sur un jeu indépendant que
j'ai achetés sur le xbox live pour la
modique somme de 1 euro à savoir
l'équivalent de ce rouleau de pq
bon allez encore me suis pas trop à quoi
m'attendre
ah ok donc elle a acheté une maison et
j'en dise qu'elle chantait à cause de
rumeurs a décidé de passer mais donnant
on l'a jamais fait après c'est une
histoire karim là bonjour c'est pour
l'entretien du monde c'est bye a été
facilitée super lourd bon ça arrive d'un
wc les jeux comme ça ils vont tous
savaient début quitté ouchy sur
rencontre coquine
tapez 3 o6 8,8 non envoi pitt aus 6 8 8
non on voit titre otis 8,8 d'accord tout
va bien donc ça c'est des souches que je
dois faire
on les obtient qts que vous avez été
pompé sur le style jamais pour jouer
avec tout va bien
à le jeune acteur le mieux du monde à el
al a pas de mode de la meilleure actrice
regard si doux si elle est dans une
maison hantée
avec un bébé et elle sourit alors qui a
tout pour ce chiffre quoique game over
depuis quand on peut perdre une partie
sur un jeu aussi pourri que ça bon il
faut que jack aisée le fag enjoy
bon allez c'est reparti [ __ ] mais
grave et en plus on doit tous retaper
super chiant comme jeu quand même
beaucoup
c'est ici pour un autre film c'est
chiant parce que google chuté eux et bah
tu va regarder la vidéo donc ton jeu il
est nul
parce quand même une femme qui est dans
une maison où tout est éteint elle
trouve une petite artère en plein boom
pouvoir genre le signe qu'une espèce de
fait des fantômes à la con qu elle
apprend la caresse elle sourit les
bordels alors l'histoire du jour c'est
un mec qui est venu taper des baraques
sa femme qui se sont donné rendez vous
il se retourne et ils ont tourné de
série de vidéos et offert un but sur
youtube des sédentaires un jour d'en
faire un jockey pouvant 1 euros sur xbox
live c'est toujours ça autant vous dire
que le titre ça me fait penser aux trucs
des hôpitaux ça fait mal au crâne par
des cas merde je dois nul
le mec de ce vote groupé revers
pourquoi game over
pourquoi game over c'est une [ __ ] de
blague
sans dec n'importe quoi je fais leur tu
t'es à la con lights et y gagnant
puisque les touches et on va serait
peut-être de mort un oil originalité ah
bon et en plus derrière je me fais kent
dans une espèce de fumée blanche qui
sortait de l'écran serait ce le mec de
sofia non non quand même pas tu t'es eu
mon dieu était géré lui tombe sur la
tête qu'elle meure or quelle forme
trajet on ne l'a jamais revu cette
nuit-là l'étagère lui est tombé dessus
je vois mon rang flanc mais pas dormir
là devraient jouer les quarts et mon
show pas une bague de fiançailles mais
contador mais si on la laissait mourir
tous les moyens qu'on laisse mourir il
ya un peu de sang sur la carte
j'ai avec lui tu viens de te réveiller
qu'est ce tu veux redevenir c'est pire
canado cette femme c'est pire qu'un bébé
le même café jus a totalement exploité
sa copine je suis désolée la ligoter la
force à faire sa musique aux oreilles et
la poupée de thaler qui criait quoi le
bruit de bébé trop mal fait tu peux être
un bruit de singe mais c'est quoi on va
mettre un bruit de singe ça aurait fait
aussi peur en fait est là elle va
prendre un couteau
ouah thunder c'est un de man is back
qu'est ce que c'est un miroir c'est leur
retour de mail pattes et à beauregard
regardez regardez sa tête de niese jour
où ça j'aime bien ça ça c'est millions
ça c'est très mignon labassa prochaine
sur déglingue avait fait toi dézinguer
allez vas-y amène un mec dessus c'est un
mec en fait monsieur c'est claude à coup
sûr le bourreau des mavs grosse tête
ok
r
mais pas morte elle est même pas marre t
on se tape un game over
mais c'est quoi cette merde moi c'est
promis je ne ferai plus jamais de vidéos
sur un jour c'est pourri que ça hein
c'est inintéressant
on se doit dans une nouvelle vidéo
notamment bientôt avec mon frère surtout
monfils à bientôt
dormez bien rassurez vous c'est que des
conneries pis à bientôt
l'état